what is going on everybody welcome to
part four of the reinforcement learning
with stable bass lines three tutorial
series in the last video we were
using a custom environment converting it
to a doom environment and training a
reinforcement learning agent on that
environment and the idea there was just
to kind of show how you could convert an
environment but also to show that you
can't just slap something into a
reinforcement learning algorithm and
expect it to just work right away so in
this case we could see that things were
sort of quote unquote working but not
very well so the episode length did
increase because dying was penalizing um
and then we also saw the reward was like
slowly going up but not how it should it
should be should have been improving
much quicker i am tempted to continue
training this model just for my own
curiosity's sake and maybe someone else
will as well
um but
it really isn't it wasn't learning
quickly enough so um so what i want to
talk about today is the steps that i at
least went through when i was like
trying to convert this for the tutorial
and i think i'm going to skip the
like
the process of like trying to code it in
and then run it and then all that kind
of stuff simply because the changes are
so minimal i think it would be
better for everyone if i just explain
what the changes were show it in the
code and then show the results
immediately so so that's what we're
going to do so i've pulled up this other
tensor board and this is going to be the
baseline so it's basically the same
exact thing that we were just looking at
a moment ago in this case the
the reward really never actually got any
better and the only difference here just
in case someone is curious
is um
in the calculation of the reward here it
was a much more temporary short-term
boost if you did happen to get an apple
so
in this case the the we were calculating
a
wee me anyway total reward that total
reward was how long is the snake minus
three because three is what the length
of the snake starts at so we're not
gonna reward the snake for showing up
and then we were saying that the you
know current quote unquote reward is
going to be the self.total reward minus
whatever the previous reward was so
really
frame by frame the only way you're gonna
get a reward is if you got an apple if
you get an apple great otherwise we
don't care so
so um so yeah and then if we were done
the same reward negative 10 basically so
a punishment of 10. and that was really
the only difference and so we can
actually just curiously already see what
was the difference between those you
know very uh
rare and more spread out rewards
it really didn't learn anything at all
versus what we did in the tutorial which
was basically if you ever did get a
reward you continued being rewarded for
that and then if if you happened to get
a couple more like at some point it got
like three apples um
you would continue getting rewarded for
that and again that's why i'm kind of i
would be slightly curious to to continue
training that one because that might
actually work out you know so anyways so
very interesting information right there
uh continuing along uh the next thing
that i wanted to train simply because
when i was developing this it really
wasn't learning anything was okay what
if we punish
um like what if we use the distance to
the apple as like a reward or punishment
so my next thought was to use the
euclidean distance
so the euclidean distance is just that
like straight line distance from one
coordinate to another coordinate so the
further away from the apple we are the
larger the euclidean distance will be
the closer to the apple that we are the
smaller that euclidean distance will be
so naturally it was like well we could
just make that a punishment then because
it will be larger the further away we
are so i modified the total reward to
just simply be the length of self.snake
position minus three which was what it
was before and then simply minus the
euclidean distance so the further away
we are from that apple the more we're
just gonna be just pounded with
punishment so so i thought that was a
pretty good idea and um
maybe some of you are already seeing the
error in my ways but
but anyways let's pull up the result
from
that one and compare
and in fact we'll just run just that one
for now and i think it's these buttons
here yes so the episode length one thing
you should notice quite quickly is whoa
the episode lengths are getting really
short
and the rewards starting you know very
very low basically off the charts low um
they do come up but they never exceed a
negative 10 what's going on well
i'm not even going to play this agent
but
but basically what happened is the agent
essentially is realizing that life is
very punishing and the best way
to uh it's very morbid but the best way
to uh earn the highest reward is to
immediately
and
end the game okay
so so so what happened was i was
training this and then i walked away and
i came back and then the screen like the
game screen was just solid black and i
was like oh no something broke or
whatever and i couldn't figure out what
was going on but then i was like oh i
saw i could clearly see things were
still running but no it was just the
agent was just instantly
we'll call it running into itself
just over and over and over so
anyway i think it's kind of kind of
funny
so yeah terrible idea so then i'm like
okay i see so so what i've done is i've
just made punishment so high and this
agent can instantly
end the game so one thing that was
interesting about this environment
versus the previous and or other snake
environments in general that i've played
you can't like in this snake environment
if the snake is like going left and you
just hit the key to go right that will
count as like you ran into yourself so
it's it you can instantly end the game
like before anything happens
so anyway cool
um
so this would be like an unintended
consequence like i i didn't even think
of this as like oh the agent might just
end up doing that because that wasn't
even in in like a re it wasn't
reasonable um but it's very logical and
that's the problem so
after that
i got to this version of snake so
coming down here it was pretty much just
okay we still want to use the euclidean
distance but then we need something to
like
offset that euclidean distance so
basically we're going to say the reward
is just 250 right out of the gate 250
minus the euclidean distance that way
if it learns to at least start getting
close to an apple um that's going to be
way more rewarding than um
ending the game so
that's cool we could have ended there
but my fear was if i just did that it
the agent might just go in circles
around the apple
so instead i also
did okay well plus and some sort of
apple reward what is the apple reward
quite literally 10 000.
so then finally because everything was
getting very astronomical i just decided
okay well after all of that i'll divide
by 100
and that will be the um self.total
reward and then i believe yeah the
reward for the actual step is total
reward so no more of these like frame by
frame things it's just constant total
reward so the more apples that you've
eaten
um or or actually the longer this or
well you'll see in this case it wouldn't
even be the longest we're not even
taking that into account so really it's
just how close are you to the apple and
if you happen to get an apple we we want
to reward it so greatly that the reward
for chasing down apples is higher than
just doing a circle because once you get
the apple now you're further away from
the apple so you're missing out on all
these like 250 rewards so
this is something that i think needs to
be further tweaked honestly from the
results that i got but if we check the
tensorboard we can
rescale rescale and we can see the
rewards are much much higher much more
appropriate rewards
for this agent so now we can actually
play this agent uh just to kind of see
where it is uh let's take down the
smoothing
and let's get a time that's episode
length let's get a reward that we like
why does it still like go off the chart
that's annoying
um
okay so in this case uh step eight eight
four
so probably like eight eight
i guess we would have to go like eight
eight oh
or
i guess 890 so can we get 890 of
80 26 let's see if that's
apparently that one didn't oh you know
what i did
how about i okay so we'll just take the
most the latest
we'll take 880.
so oops so we'll copy that come over
here
uh
we'll go to pl oh that's not what i want
i thought that was the arrow key how do
i do this
okay we'll come over here models uh
we'll take that model and then we will
do step
880 000
we will load it up we'll just play
infinite episodes
of our friendly snek game
uh python 3 play snake
move this over here
and yeah so here we have the snake game
as you can see he's does definitely he
the snake spends time sometimes circling
around the apple or near the apple but
in general uh it looks pretty good it's
getting the apple just ran into itself
unfortunately um
and yeah so i mean it clearly has
learned something now i know that this
could be improved considerably from this
point um my guess is the observations
need to be improved because the snake
does run into itself which is weird um
and then and the moves that the snake is
willing to do are clearly like these
like really big arching moves so my
guess is the snake actually has not
figured out where the where the other
bits where the other parts of the snake
are so um i think that that's probably
something that would be improved but
hard to say it's just really trial and
error um and that really wasn't my point
with doing this tutorial was not to just
continue solving the snake game so i'm
going to leave it here but feel free to
tinker with it and try various ideas and
if you get a really awesome model please
do share it with me i'm curious to see
what people can come up with to do make
an even better model so
anyway um i think that's all for now uh
like i said i just kind of wanted to
show some of the things that i worked
through just to and in this case it was
really just all reward stuff but there
are probably tweaks that could be made
to the observation as well and really
just things you need to think about when
you
are creating your own custom model
because or a custom environment rather
because these things won't just be
handed to you and even things that you
think are reasonable or all you'll need
is these things you'll you'll find that
you actually have to kind of
hand engineer
these things so
anyways that's all for now questions
comments concerns whatever you can feel
free to leave them below otherwise i
will see you all in another video
you